hi there this is steve kaufman founder
of link
uh continuing in my series of uh seven
secrets to successful language learning
and uh again i'll review them as i
always do the first one was to spend the
time
the second was to do things you like to
do in language learning
the third thing was to develop the
ability to notice what's happening in
the language the fourth secret was to
focus on words rather than grammar
the fifth secret was to be patient
now the sixth secret is
a matter of strategy or tactics if you
want and that is
make sure you
get the tools that you need to be
successful
if you're fixing something up around the
house you need the proper tools any job
is easier if you have the proper tools
so
obviously you need to have an mp3 player
i don't want to promote any one brand
but i have an ipod touch
i have an ipod shuffle which is a
smaller
um
mp3 player which is more convenient when
i go jogging and it's lighter
the ipod touch has a number of
advantages on it on my ipod touch i have
bought
uh online dictionaries dictionaries for
the ipod
in all of i don't know 12 different
languages
uh and i try the free dictionaries and
if they're no good then i spend the
money to get a good dictionary
um
also
i think you should buy books uh
obviously we at link feel that we have a
wonderful platform for language learning
but i would be surprised if most of our
members don't also buy books or if you
can borrow them that's fine but
but a book will last you a long time
it's not a big investment whereas
language learning is a major investment
of your time
so i would suggest anyone beginning in a
language should buy one of these
beginner series if you're an english
speaker
then there's uh you know the teach
yourself series or the colloquial series
uh there's assimil which is available
for french speakers and english speakers
uh there are a number of these starter
books
get one i will often buy one or two and
uh while my main interest is listening
and and reading to the to the dialogue i
also flip through it for some of the
explanations
never expecting to remember them
but as a sort of a gradual refresher
that helps me notice
um audiobooks i'll buy a quality
audiobook
rather than rely on librivox where the
quality can be you know uncertain uh i
admit that i have an ipad and i use the
link app on the ipad and i love it i can
uh click on my yellow words i can listen
to
uh the uh
you know the the audio portion of the
lesson no not everyone is going to spend
the money on an ipad
but uh
all i'm saying is don't think that you
can do everything for free you may end
up spending more time
trying to
work around
or
using less than satisfactory
tools so
whatever your budget is make sure that
you have the have the the proper tools
in order to oh dictionaries for example
online dictionaries if they're if
they're free once available get them and
if that's good enough fine but if you
have to if you have to spring for five
dollars to get a good online dictionary
or dictionary for your ipod do it
uh ebooks whatever
uh
do make sure that you you get the proper
tools it's going to make a big
difference to your success
thank you for listening and we got one
more secret to go